what's going on guys this is Rob and
this story is going to have one of the
most amazing really some of the most
amazing moments in recent history with
the X-Men I'm so excited to cover this
so what we end up doing here right one
of the first things that happens is we
pick up in a bar with weaponless Zen now
for those of you guys who are kind of
joining us for the first time we're not
gonna go super in depth into this but
basically what you have when it comes to
mutants in Marvel Comics now is you've
got basically most earthborn mutants
that live in krakowa record was
established as like a safe haven for the
mutant population then you've got a
Rocco and what we learned is that there
was a whole other segment of mutants
that existed but in a different
dimension that just kind of had their
own place it was called a Rocco but like
we'd never seen them before it was only
during Jonathan Hickman's House of X and
powers of X that we were introduced to
them but once they came back to the main
Marvel Universe specifically back to
Earth they couldn't all stay on krakowa
for a variety of reasons one because the
island wasn't big enough although that
did kind of change over time but two
because of the fact that the ideologies
on what they value are so distinctly
different that where the mutants on
Earth really love the idea and Champion
the idea of like a peaceful coexistence
between humans and mutants such as it
was those mutants from arako have known
nothing but conflict nothing but like
conflict and strife and so on and so
forth so they value war and so because
you had these two just diametrically
opposing views the mutants that
previously existed on Morocco traveled
and took to Mars and what they ended up
doing was renaming Mars to arako or new
Oracle it depends on what you want to
call it weaponless Zen comes from
Morocco and the funny thing about her is
that she doesn't really have a power
that matters to be honest
that most powers that are championed
from Morocco are powers that are like
offensive right so the ability to shoot
energy blasts or super strength that
amplifies based on somebody's attack or
swimming along those lines for
weaponless Zen she's a person that has
the ability to paint the truth but
because she's more synonymous with like
artists and things like that she's kind
of shunned by the people of oracco and
so what she ended up doing was serving
as a kind of Emissary for arauco's inner
Council bush she doesn't really have a
home she doesn't believe in the krakowan
views of the world but the people on
Morocco won't really accept her so she's
just kind of out doing her own thing
what this means is there comes a point
when she's met by her sister Cora along
with cable now one of the things to know
here is that when a Rocco became its own
place out there on Mars that storm
basically became kind of the de facto
leader of oracos so to speak but really
more the shoe is just kind of like
initially started out as like krakowa's
stand-in as a representative on oracco
in the same way that like the United
States has a seat in the United Nations
that kind of thing and so what this
meant is that when it came to weaponless
Zen and her sister Cora they were
actually the daughters of fisher king
now we're not going to go super in depth
into him in fact he's a really
mysterious character so there really
isn't anything to talk about
but the reality here is that Abigail
brand has basically been leading sword
the sentient World observation and
response department and while what goes
on in kakawa is not the concern of
Abigail brand what goes on on oracco is
and so what she's been doing is actually
vying to have really one of her own
agents placed on the inner Council in
iroco in the aftermath of Judgment Day
when some of those members on the
council died right so it's kind of like
a Game of Thrones type thing but for
Cora herself she has the ability to
amplify the powers of others but with
cable coming to the realization of what
Abigail Brand's been trying to do the
entire nature of this mission that he
kind of calls together where he brings
in weapon listen is to actually take
down Abigail brand and in fact go as far
as to kill her that's the idea now
there's a few reasons why this is the
case ever since Abigail brand was has
been introduced in Marvel Comics back
during Joss whedon's astonishing X-Men
she's always been a very manipulative
person she'll be cool to you and she'll
be nice but with her right hand she'll
shake your hand and greet you and with
her left hand she'll be preparing to
stab you in the back and so with cable
real realizing this is the case the best
person to control sword is a person this
actually mutant friendly so that's the
idea is to basically take her out now
the other story that's going on here
actually switches us over to the arako
Diplomatic Zone where you basically have
payback who is a member of the scroll
Cree delegation meaning at some point
recently the scroll and the cree stopped
Waging War against each other and they
unified as a singular Army which
basically scares the crap out of
everybody because they're two of the
most powerful forces in the world and so
you have the Shia race which is
concerned about this because their fear
is that this scroll Cree Alliance could
actually topple the Shia Empire and wipe
it out or at least take over its entire
Kingdom so it's really just a fear of
Kingdoms being overthrown by other
kingdoms but one of the things that goes
on here is you have Abigail brand kind
of watching all this and she's getting
ready to put one of her pieces in
position so that's kind of the cool
thing here but what goes on is payback
actually tells a story and what he says
here is that at some time or at least at
some point in time the cree received
word of a breach of the pan world's Arms
Treaty and that his people were were
allegedly conducting forbidden genetic
weapons research at a secret facility
codenamed shapeless rich and that the
cree command decided that a small force
of stealth Warriors could destroy the
facility where a larger Force might fail
the experimental Cree super soldier
Captain Glory LED that Force he
succeeded admirably massacring every
single scroll who was there in fact they
barely put up a fight because shapeless
Ridge did not make weapons it was a
treatment facility for wounded Scrolls
no longer able to shapeshift civilians
by any measure the intelligence was
wrong that what had happened is the cree
under false information had attacked a
uh what amounted to a hospital now the
problem with this is the rift between
the cree and the scroll was so long
standing right because it had been gone
all it'd been going on for millions of
years at this point the rift was so
extreme and so irreparable that the cree
refused to accept the fact that they did
anything wrong they basically put out
this idea that the Scrolls were lying
about the nature of shapeless Ridge and
that basically led to the two Nations
going back into war against now this is
before you had everything going on with
like hulkling and so on with unifying
the empires and whatnot but the thing
about this is he asked the question what
they learned over time is that the Creed
did not act alone they were actually fed
this information so who do you think
gave them this information now of course
he's really telling this story to
Gladiator and that's when when the
questions asked who do you think fed
that information they're met by Sandra
basically the queen of the Shia race who
says we did and it's one of the great
sins right one of the great failings of
the Shia race she refers to it
specifically as one of the 10 shames
that their kin Crimson sought to bury
really like the Shia tried to hide that
fact from everything else and so what
ends up happening here is that when
Zandra makes her presence known that's
when Abigail brand says initiate the
plan and so in the midst of this whole
meeting with everybody talking there
that there's this great accuse
discussion on what the shiar Empire
could possibly offer in restitution of
what they'd done what they could
possibly give for the things that they
had committed before right this heinous
act that led to the cree wiping out so
many Scrolls but before any of them can
answer the response here is I offer fire
and literally Vulcan shows back up again
and says my fire and Inferno that will
burn your pathetic Alliance where it
lies if you dare to stand against your
betters Rejoice bold men of the Shia
raise your swords and sing your hassanas
your King has returned now here's the
cool thing about this right because this
is quite literally the return of Vulcan
right and it's like literally Abigail
Brands like check and make so let's
let's take a step back from this story
for a second let's talk about a story
called X-Men deadly Genesis and then
we'll talk about something called the
rise and fall of the shiar so one of the
things we learned with X-Men deadly
Genesis is that if you remember giant
size X-Men number one if you saw my
video on it the original X-Men were
basically captured by the mutant island
of kakoa this is long before it becomes
their safe haven but they were captured
by the mutant island of krakowa Xavier
put together a second team with storm
and Wolverine and Nightcrawler and
Colossus and all of them in order to
rescue the original team and then the
new X-Men went forward from there what
deadly Genesis gave us was this idea
that there was actually a secret X-Men
team that Xavier had put together that
nobody knew about the mission was a
disaster and everybody but Vulcan and
Darwin dot now Vulcan would have died
but Darwin being a mutant that can adapt
to any circumstance basically immersed
his life force with Vulcan and what that
did is it allowed Vulcan to just kind of
rest really go into more of a dormant
state but after the events of House of M
he woke up right just like this huge
surge in mutant power just Vanishing led
to him waking up but showing up on Earth
was just like a vendetta against Xavier
only to find out that Xavier has been
missing since after House of M was gone
this led to Vulcan attacking the X-Men
now ultimately Xavier returns and
vulcan's given his history where he's
told that the X-Men aren't the reason
why his parents are dead right that sure
Xavier apologizes for screwing up the
whole mission and everything going south
but what he says is like the father of
Cyclops and Havoc which is also the
father of Vulcan was taken by the Shia
race right so like literally the
slaughtering of his family the
destruction of his family was the result
of the shiar not the X-Men and so once
Gabriel's given this truth he
immediately takes off to the shiar
Empire that goes into a story called The
Rise and Fall of the shiar Empire where
he basically conquers it and turns into
just a mad tyrannical King right he just
rules it with an iron fist he's this
crazy Emperor and ultimately that ends
during the war of King's storyline where
he fights uh fights Black Bolt and is
basically locked inside the fault which
turns out to be the cancer verse but the
thing about this is that that's kind of
the long and short of vulcan's History
there's a lot more to it than that but
as one of the most powerful mutants in
existence right in Omega Level mutant in
his own right for a while here in the
X-Men red Comics that what Abigail
Brand's been trying to do is get him
into a position where one she can
control him and two he can literally
carry out her campaigns and allow her to
do the things she kind that she really
wants to do without actually getting her
hands dirty now the question has to be
asked here how in the world did Vulcan
come back that's actually a thing that
we'll talk about here in a minute now of
course we will also get back to the
story of cable in them because that's
where things get really really cool but
the response of what's going on with
Vulcan vulcan's arrival is exactly what
you would expect it to be right
everybody responds exactly how you would
expect them to Richard Ryder Nova who
lives lived through the war of Kings and
the Shia war on the rest of the world or
rest of the universe like the response
of gladiator who had to serve Vulcan as
the leader of the Imperial Guard all
these guys respond just like you would
think they would which was this is
ridiculous like somebody get this guy
out of here this guy is a crazy King
like he will kill us all now of course
on the service you would think that
gladiator would be the person best
suited to take on Vulcan and under any
normal circumstance he would but lest we
forget Vulcan has the ability to
manipulate every form of energy in
existence it doesn't matter what it is
this guy is one story arc away from
becoming someone who has the power to
alter reality on the same level as
Franklin Richards just no one's done it
yet right but if they did it would be
believable right this guy can manipulate
every form of energy right off the bat
he takes out Gladiator and it's the
smartest move because one of the things
to remember is that the power of
strontians is tied to their confidence
so if their confidence wanes their power
wanes with it and what what Vulcan does
is he literally takes out a gladiator by
saying that he's got his prefrontal
cortex which is in large and that's what
helps to amplify his power by bolstering
his confidence even if the confidence is
false but with all those neurons
floating around in there right all that
that electrical energy quote unquote if
you want to call it that Vulcan Taps
into that reroutes it shuts it down
nullifies the confidence of gladiator
and he's as weak as any fumbling child
so it's amazing how it happens the
second person that attacks him is of
course Richard Ryder wielding the full
entirety of the Nova Force but literally
Vulcan just seizes the Nova force from
Richard Ryder and then in turn attacks
him with his own power and takes out
Richard Ryder now following that you
have warbird right you have like the
sister of Alandra if you want to call
her that but you have Warburg that jumps
in along with frenzy now warbird is
she's capable she can do some cool stuff
sometimes she banged uh Gabriel and like
they have a kid who's just kind of
shuffled off to some place where he's
safe from everything frenzy is the cool
one right frenzy is really really cool
she's like a female version of Luke Cage
but in fact she goes all the way back to
the old X Factor comics with uh Bob
Layton Jackson geese and then Louise
Simonson it was cool because she is a
Powerhouse but if course one of the
things about this is that while all this
is going on this is happening pay box
destroyed right in front of frenzy by
Vulcan because friends and this is one
thing to understand frenzy's never seen
this kind of thing before I mean she
messed around with Apocalypse in the
sense that like she was an agent of
Apocalypse that kind of stuff and she's
done some shady stuff but watching a guy
show up and by himself annihilate some
of the most powerful beings in the
universe she's never really seen that
and that's why it absolutely terrifies
her in a lot of ways but Abigail brand
is watching all this unfold and she's
like Yep this is uh kind of what needed
to happen here right it's nuts to see it
all happen and so and probably one of
the most genius bits of writing here
Vulcan realizes he can't destroy
frenzy's physical form because it's
beyond his power right she's just
exceedingly durable she's got
indestructible skin but what he does
realize is she has to breathe so sure
Fire won't burn her but it will burn the
oxygen around her and that's literally
what he does he sets the air on fire
around her head and burns out the oxygen
which basically doesn't kill her but it
does knock her out or at least I don't
think it kill her kills her maybe it
does honestly like Vulcan he doesn't he
doesn't really care man he just he'll
kill anybody it doesn't really matter
but with everybody more or less defeated
here that what you end up having is him
turning around and attacking zondra like
trying like killing the queen of the
Shia race right the Empress of the Shia
Empire and literally that's when you
basically have Abigail brand that's like
this is exactly what I wanted because if
the queen of the Shia Empire is dead
this is much bigger than me having
somebody on the throne of arako now I
have a I have a person that's in charge
of an entire Empire the problem with
this is that once the Flames subside
Gabriel realizes it's not Zandra sitting
on the throne of the Shia Empire and in
fact it's the one person that even
Gabriel himself would not be foolish
enough to challenge it's Robert DeCosta
also known as Sunspot now I know some of
you guys are like wait a minute wait a
minute why would Gabriel Summers not
mess with that guy I will explain but
before we do we gotta jump over and talk
about cable
so with Cable's Mission underway what he
does is he gathers together some pretty
cool mutants I mean they're not overly
interesting but the reality here is this
is kind of a throwback to the old
X-Force Comics right like cable was
introduced and was it New Mutants issue
number 89 I think it was and the New
Mutants became X-Force back in the early
1990s this is basically that what you
end up having though is of course a
different roster so you basically got
Eden who has the ability to teleport
basically anybody anywhere Across the
Universe he got John proud star who's
just really strong I mean he's okay I
mean the guy died in this in the in like
Uncanny X-Men Number 96 back in the day
two issues into Chris claremont's
running he got blown up by a plane if
that gives you any indication of how
little that guy matters core is cool
because she can amplify everybody's
Powers no idea why uh weaponless Zen is
here you of course got cable then you
have whiz kid now whiz kid is the
coolest member of the group and the
reason why is because he can tap into
virtually any form of technology and
even organic matter to a degree and he
can reshape it and turn it into anything
he wants to so to anybody who's just
flying around space and doesn't know
that whiz kid is in this ship this ship
would look like a trans former right it
like turns from a ship into like a giant
robot or something like that but like
whiz kid can do all that stuff he's
basically an anime character like for
those of you guys who like anime imagine
that you could basically make like giant
uh what is it Jaeger I think is what
they call them you could just make those
out of anything and like that's what
this guy can do he's like an anime
character in comic books it's just
really awesome but of course the focal
point of this Mission the main idea
behind this is that there comes a point
when Eden kind of asked the question
okay so like what in the world is going
on here the responsive cable is simple
he says might as well bring everybody up
to speed recently Abigail brand
triggered the resurrection protocols
meaning she died but a resurrection via
cerebro only goes back so far right so
she died and she was brought back on
krakowa and of course her memory is
being returned to her was only for so
long so one of the first things she did
when she came out of basically
Resurrection is she started checking her
files to see what she was missing but at
the same time Wizkid and cable were
checking them as well and they saw
everything and cable says which isn't
everything just the most recent file
still it's pretty damning Abigail brand
is working with orcas now of course
orcas is the largely anti-mutant
organization that's composed of
basically everybody there's members from
the world governments who are part of
orcas you've got Advanced idea mechanics
Hydra you got all kinds of people
they're friends of humanity and so on
and so forth the right you have all
these organizations the only ones you
don't have on there are the purifiers as
far as I'm aware but basically what he
says is that she's either working with
them or she's playing them whatever the
case it happens to be to her all of this
krakowa and arako is a temporary
situation that can be leveraged to
advance more important goals wheels
turning on a scale so large that we
could all be crushed in their gears and
so what he says is Brands not just
working with orcas she's partnered with
a rimworld diplomat named orbis
Stellaris he's a gene Tech entrepreneur
of Unknown Origin rumor has it that he
also runs a profitable sideline in
bioweapons including militarized cloning
quite a well-rounded individual now of
course not really a pawn or anything
like that but what we end up finding out
is that somewhere along the line that
Abigail brand had partnered with Orvis
virus to steal to steal a sample of
Cable's techno-organic virus the
basically the machine component that you
see with him that allows him to tap into
like machinery and different things like
that one of the things that he mentions
and in fact it's a really really cool
idea when cable was basically brought
back to life when he was resurrected
they considered getting rid of his
techno-organic virus because he has to
channel his telekinesis to keep the
Machinery from eating his body alive and
so that really kind of cuts his powers
in half but what he does is he gives a
sample of his virus to Eden and says you
can trace anything in the universe
because you literally talk to the
universe you've got Cosmic awareness and
he says so there's only two samples of
my techno-organic virus this one that I
just gave you and the one that was
stolen take us to the one that was
stolen and so they basically teleport
him to what's basically the world form
right this place that kind of exists out
on the fringes of space now here's a
funny thing about this is that what
starts happening is cable starts talking
about the progenitors he says the the
world Farm is the home of the
progenitors here's the issue about this
these guys basically kind of made their
debut in the the old Royals comic from
2017 by Al Ewing we don't really know a
whole lot about him all we know is that
they were the ones who created the cree
race but outside of that we don't really
have any information and in fact as far
as I'm aware Al Ewing has not really
offered any information to establish
where the progenitors exist in relation
to the celestials because one of the
things that you guys will notice if
you're reading Marvel Comics right now
specifically Al Ewing the entire history
as we know it in terms of how these
different races came into existence and
all that kind of stuff has all just been
blown to Pieces it's all just been
annihilated and Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers a new Avengers he established
that the builders were responsible for
creating all life Across the Universe
but then you go into alien's ultimates
after the events of uh Secret Wars is
over Elite Secret Wars 2015 and it's
like well the celestials created
everything right they're the ones that
are in charge of all things in existence
Builders don't really have a part in
that they're just a really old race that
exists out there so it's one of those
things where now Al Ewing's kind of
going back and cleaning all this stuff
up all the stuff up in terms of the
Marvel continuity and even the Marvel
Cosmic hierarchy now I think a lot of
that's being done because of the MCU in
order order to allow the average
moviegoer to see what's in the MCU and
then to translate that to the comic
books it makes good sense if you're
trying to build up you know trying to
make money in that way but again it's
all just kind of cleanup Duty so in
terms of like the origins of everything
in existence in the Marvel Universe it's
all in a state of flux so if anybody
comes along and they say this is
definitively how things happen they
don't know what they're talking about
because all that's being changed at the
moment anything is a possibility right
now and we just kind of have to wait
till the dust settles and now Ewing is
effectively done with all this stuff
before we can actually give any concrete
answers so once they basically make
their way aboard the world ship right
the the world farm that one thing end up
realizing is that this piece or this bit
of the techno-organic virus is still
being held here in stasis the problem is
they meet these kind of progenitor
beings right these beings that seem to
exist not really beyonders but they come
from outside the universe nothing's
really known about them we don't really
know where they come from we don't know
what their story is or how powerful they
are we simply just know that they're
there but what it ended up happening
here is that there's a kind of broadcast
right a sort of camera feed on almost
the cable is able to tap into that
actually shows him what these guys had
been doing and what they say is that
some small microscopic measure that
given fertile soil could grow into
something more it's a cancer of course
referring to the good that's in this
particular person that they're talking
to and that is unacceptable for the work
we have set in front of you so we've
separated the two inside hidden under a
thin layer of that good is the beautiful
broken creature that you are we're going
to release you back into your Universe
they will see you as changed reborn
healthy and whole but that is just a
shell buried underneath buried alive in
a shallow grave is the real you and
they're talking about Vulcan right so
this is why these two stories intersect
and this is why we wanted to cover it
well I want to cover this before we got
to the rest of what was going on so when
it came to Vulcan right the thing to
understand about his character when it
came to Vulcan yes after the events of
War of Kings Vulcan was basically gone
we hadn't seen hide nor hear that guy
and by all standards the measurement he
was dead and then you go into Jonathan
Hickman's X-Men and he's just suddenly
back and we didn't really know how we
got back we just knew that he was there
what this does is it establishes that
when Vulcan had returned in the X-Men
comics and he was suddenly a good guy
whereas previously he was just a crazy
nut job that essentially lost his mind
and become drunk with power where we
didn't know how the how that whole thing
was bridged this answers that question
that is all manipulation Vulcan is still
very much just the crazy Mad King but
the illusion of him being a good guy was
put there in order to allow him to be
brought back into the X-Men in order to
convince the X-Men that he would
actually be a good guy and he could
benefit the rest of humanity and so what
ends up happening here of course coming
to this realization that in the midst of
all this a giant guy with a golden head
just descends down and starts attacking
everybody and so on the face of this
assault of course cable and his guys do
what they can where they can and for the
most part they're able to overcome this
guy right the body comes crashing down
and the golden head just kind of rolls
and then crashes into a wall but the
being inside the golden head right orbis
Stellaris ends up activating the other
three progenitors right those three
beings who were out there and when they
activate they immediately start going on
the attack now the funny thing about
this is despite doing that they don't
really do a whole lot per se instead all
they really do is they study and they
analyze the entire nature of Eden
himself right manifold which is the name
that he used to have but they study him
in terms of his connection with the
universe how he's able to talk to the
universe but there's not a whole lot
doing that and the biggest reason for
this is that using the power of or
really with Cora using her abilities to
amplify the telekinesis of cable what it
does is it allows him to pull the
techno-organic virus from the stasis
stasis Cube into himself and then add
the techno-organic virus to his body's
structure which of course gives him just
this really dope looking armor if the
most 1990s thing ever I mean he's even
got the pouches man like look at the
look at the pouches dude he's even got
the patches around his waist tell me I
mean and there's a reason why you can't
see his feet Rob liefeld couldn't draw
feet back in the day and he still can't
but the thing here is that this attack
between cable and the really you want to
call it his own X-Force scheme but
between him and his team they launched
their attack against basically the
forces of orbis Stellaris as well as
these progenitor guys they do try to
seize the the Techno organic virus off
of cable ultimately they're unsuccessful
because Eden's able to basically
teleport them back to wherever they came
from and like that's basically it right
with you know orbit Stellaris or at
least this orb you know more or less
defeated them not truly understanding
what's going on here that they
ultimately just leave right like that's
literally a kid was like okay well let's
go ahead and get out of here now I got
my techno organic virus back let's go
ahead and bounce and so what we're going
to do here is we're going to jump back
to what was going on with Robert DeCosta
now here's the thing and here's the
reason why I say that Vulcan is smart
enough not to mess with Robert DeCosta
so one of the things that happens here
is that with all this fire and all this
stuff around here that Vulcan threatens
to use the very fire around Robert
DeCosta against him but remember Robert
Acosta is living fire he's living
burning plasma and that's the thing is
he says I don't draw my energy from the
Sun I can draw my energy from anything
with thermal energy so how about I just
draw all the energy out of you right I
can just bleed you dry like a vampire
take every ounce of energy G out of you
and leave you as a dead husk right
that's why Gabriel will not screw with
Robert DeCosta because Robert could kill
him because no matter how hot the fire
is that Vulcan uses it'll never injure
Robert DeCosta and so he ultimately just
leaves right he literally just takes off
now he ends up traveling to what is
basically the Autumn place where the
Brotherhood of mutants under Magneto
would meet and talk and all that kind of
stuff at least as far as a a Rocco went
but when he gets there his idea is that
this is where Zandra is hiding out this
is where zondra's staying at the moment
right she's basically kind of off
location hiding out here until the whole
thing's done and then they come and get
her what's actually going on when he
arrives here is he's met by storm now
here's the thing right storm is another
Omega Level mutant and this is where
things get a little bit murky and it's
actually where power fluctuations come
into play so Vulcan does get into a
fight with storm and he gets into a
fight with storm and he is able to hold
his own against storm and in fact storm
is able to hold her own against his and
she goes as far as to say like we are
equally matched in power now that's not
true and that was never true there's
never been an instance where storm has
been equal to Vulcan and power this is
either Storm's Powers being Amplified or
vulcan's Powers being reduced the
reality here is Vulcan is more than
enough to be able to take out storm I
mean the ability to manipulate any form
of energy means he can manipulate the
electronics the electromagnetic spectrum
and now he's got the powers of Magneto
and just literally pull her body apart
the same way that Magneto ripped the
body of Apocalypse in half during like
the Age of Apocalypse there's a million
ways that Vulcan could kill her in the
here and now but it's not designed to be
an instance where Storm is looking to
destroy him that what she's actually
looking to do here is literally just
stalemate him right in the here and now
to stalemate this guy and that's exactly
what she does that between storm and
alongside her Brotherhood that they're
able to basically at least hold off
Vulcan long enough to encase him in
mysterium a nigh Unstoppable form of
metal that exists out there now the
fight between the two is cool and I
don't want to take away from that right
the fight between storm and and Vulcan
is awesome and it's a fight for the ages
but I think this also speaks to the
level of power that storm has that she's
able to hold her own now I think a lot
of this might also just be because of
the fact that people sleep on storm they
sleep on how powerful this chick is I
don't know somebody you know people are
going to be like nobody's sleeping on
how powerful storming no they kind of do
actually one because people who've never
read Comics they've only ever seen her
in in the fox movies and Halle Berry's
depiction of storm was basically trash
Storm's a horse man again I'd say under
normal circumstances she's nowhere near
as powerful as Vulcan is but she's she's
strong man like she's ridiculously op
but again with the assistance of her own
Brotherhood specifically Lotus logos who
has the ability to basically kind of
create metals or mysterium serum as
seemingly out of nowhere with his powers
they encase Vulcan here and he's he's
locked in this location now again this
is really just marvel kind of keeping
him like over there right like it's it's
putting it's putting a book on the Shelf
is really all it is we'll bring it back
later that's really all that's happening
here so he'll return at some future
point in time he's not really dead so
what we end up doing here is we switch
back over to Abigail brand and she's
watching everything with like Vulcan and
storm and all of that stuff happened now
the fact that she's in communication
with Vulcan means that she would have
warned him if she'd known storm was
there but Abigail brand didn't know
storm was there which is weird because
she used equipment to scan the area to
see if there was anybody with a mutant
signature who was there and so the
indication is that the equipment missed
storm but the reality here is the
equipment didn't miss storm it told her
storm was there which means somebody's
messing with her head and basically
treating her into believing that storm
wasn't there at all that there was no
one there outside of Vulcan himself now
the entire time that she's been
communicating telepathically with Vulcan
and all those guys has been done by way
of mentalo or mintalo if you want to
call him that but he's basically a low
level telepath and so where he's not
powerful enough to mess with her head
because she literally says I've been
through almost every form of psychic
training that a person could possibly
imagine I've been to the Xavier red
triangle protocol so like Xavier himself
has trained me on how to Shield my mind
and so she says the only way a person
could mess with my head is if they were
if I was on a aware of the fact that
they were doing that and they were a
person who was a sufficiently powerful
telepath somebody on the same level as
Professor Xavier and so that's when
natalo Chimes up and says when you all
here zondra is pretty powerful but the
response of Abigail brand is not
powerful enough to get to me without me
knowing unless she was right up close in
this room and I've got my red triangle
going right now if she was that close
I'd see her unless she used a relay a
fellow telepath to carry her signal and
that's when she puts two and two
together and realizes that it's actually
Zandra using the power of mentalo to
influence Abigail brand not only that
she starts to realize that the reason
why or at least the person kind of
manipulating this all on a larger level
is actually Sunspot himself Robert
DeCosta he's got the means the resources
the money that kind of thing but he has
the ability to bring the right people
together to make this all happen in the
first place and so quite literally it's
a multi-faceted attempt by Robert
DeCosta to actually remove Abigail bran
as Direct of sort because the entirety
of the mutant population sees her as a
credible threat to the mutant population
and in a lot of ways she is as a person
who would protect Earth against any
threat she would attack the mutant
population if she needed to not only
that her political manipulating and
things like that is more than the mutant
population is willing to tolerate here
and so again with the help of Robert
DeCosta zondra literally steps up like
you tried to have me killed as an
empress of of a world a ruler of an
entire Empire you literally tried to
orchestrate a coup d'etat you gotta go
and so like they're gonna kill her
they're gonna kill Abigail brand and in
fact they would probably ensure that she
would not come back to the resurrection
protocols such as it is she ends up body
Sliding Away right using her
teleportation or teleportation
technology to body slide by one to a
secret location that no one knows about
the funny thing about this is that when
she gets there fisher king is there now
again we don't know anything about this
guy this guy's a mystery the only thing
we know is that he lives among the
mutant population from Morocco but has
no powers and never had power but by
whatever Manner and whatever means he
gained their respect which is why they
never destroyed him but this guy's
ridiculously mysterious because all he
says is that your your grand plans are
dust Abigail the road you walked ends
here you are enemy of Morocco and for
our enemies there is only destruction
destruction is all that you are and at
the end of that road is what comes next
so we have no clue what's going to
happen to Abigail brand but she's
basically out of the picture mutants are
now in charge of the sentient World
observation and response Department if
you guys are kind of putting the pieces
together here mutants are seizing
control of every form of intelligence
around the world so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace